[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to fat man I'm Batman Kevin
Smith hi I'm Mark Barnard would you look
at this fancy [ __ ] over here I
know I'm a little fancy I just came from
explanation for the way I look cause I
don't [ __ ] look like I normally do
Iowa's on a set I was shooting something
two years ago and changed two and a half
years ago we shot a pilot for a show
called the Holly weed that I was in and
acted in and stuff two and a half years
later we just finished the pilot which
makes sense based on the [ __ ] show
and so I was on set all day and so I
wouldn't last time we shot the episode
like I love the show I'm in it with
Donnell Rawlings most people know him as
ashy Larry from the Chappelle show yes
yes but I know him as a very funny
stand-up [ __ ] guy and now a really
wonderful actor that I've worked we said
so the idea is like like when I made
clerks I wrote the role of Randall to
play myself which is why he has all the
best jokes in the movie but as we got
close to production I'm like I'm not a
[ __ ] actor I can't memorize all this
dialogue who wrote this [ __ ] you know so
I was like I gotta cast somebody else
let me take a role with no dialogue and
that's how I wound up as Silent Bob so
my first instinct was to be one of the
leads right like I was a clerk it was my
life and stuff and it was always kind of
strange when I look at it now in
perspective that I didn't play myself I
should have played Dante or you know I
wrote Randall to play myself but I
should have played Dante because that's
who I Moore was but I I wasn't confident
enough as a performer I was like I'll
[ __ ] it up I don't know how to memorize
it I'll let other people do it and stuff
and so it always you know worked out
with Silent Bob don't get me wrong but
like you could tell it's a real acting
performance because look at me I love to
talk to be quiet for that long that
takes intense concentration like that's
where I have to go method and [ __ ]
shut up and stuff so I you know the
chance to do Hollywood was the chance to
kind of go back and rewrite history a
little bit like you know Oh what would
happen if you made clerks but you did
get to be in it and stuff so it's you
know it's essentially people like what
is about I'm like it's [ __ ] clerks in
a weed store so you know it's kind of
it's been sweet so we just shot today
when we shot last time I wanted to get
back to the show cuz I was like oh my
god I've never looked better than when I
we shot the pilot I was at my adult
thinnest so I was like if I did that
show it would give me a reason to stay
thin and [ __ ] like that
then I almost [ __ ] died and so then I
found a real good reason to stay good to
get in shape it [ __ ] went vegan and
stuff and dropped 40 pounds so when we
went back to shoot again thank you but
yeah I didn't thank you I'll be honest I
did leave a little pause hoping for that
it was really [ __ ] hard I had a lot
of potatoes so so when we went back you
know to do it again like I I look
thinner now than I did then so it's not
like basically the the piece that we
shot today ends the show so essentially
every way you've seen me up till this
last scene which is like the next day
you know I'm looking like I did when we
shot it but when I show up for this PSC
and I look like I do now so I plug it
through in the line where I was like
Donelle goes I play a character named
Pete he goes Jesus Pete you look [ __ ]
thin this morning and I was like yeah I
felt bloated all day yesterday man
I said but then I took like a really
good [ __ ] feel like I lost 40 pounds man
and then we just went on from there
so I the outfit that I wore the last
time around I couldn't wear cuz it just
doesn't fit anymore and stuff so I wound
up wearing this this jacket that I'm
wearing as family history and in our
family it's a Versace jaga's the only
nice piece of clothing I ever had in my
life when I wore it at what was my adult
thinnest on Dogma and I was going to the
indie spirit awards and so I had to wear
something nice and so the costume lady
Abigail was like here man we got this
Versace jacket that they sent for Ben or
Matt to wear but they wouldn't wear it
maybe you will and so I was like I'll
take their leavings and so I put it on
and it [ __ ] fit kind of nice and [ __ ]
and she's like you look good in it and I
had like my own kind of jacket I think I
was wearing hoodies in those days but
she was like you look good in it you
deserve that jacket and I was like oh my
god thank you and I thought she was
giving it to me so I wore it and then I
got a bill for it and [ __ ] and it was
like 1,500 bucks and I was like for a
piece of [ __ ] clothing like do you
see how I normally dress so I was
already pod committed I bought it and I
was wearing it at the end of Spirit
Awards where I had essentially what was
my first date with who's now my wife
Jennifer she was a journalist at USA
Today and I had interviewed with her
like a month and change prior and then I
was coming back out to go the nd spirit
award so I was just like hey man I I
know you'd cover the award circuit
because she did the Oscars and she did
the Golden Globes and the blockbuster
Awards I just remember being like what a
weird trio like one of these things is
not like the other and one of them
doesn't even [ __ ] exist anymore man
so you know I was like you go to all the
award ceremonies are you going to the
indie Spirit Awards she's like no we
don't cover that and I was like [ __ ] and
she goes why and I was like I'm going to
that origin you're like the only person
I know in Los Angeles which was a
[ __ ] lie but she was like really I
was like yeah I figure we could meet
there like we don't have to go as a date
or something but we just meet there and
stuff and hang out and she's like um
yeah okay let's do that
so I went to the show and I wound up
winning an award for writing chasing amy
and stuff and so I was wearing this
jacket and then after the [ __ ] show I
was wearing this and I was wearing jeans
and I said hey man can we go back to
your place so I can get out of these
clothes and she's like [ __ ] you and I
said no I just want to put on some I
said this is too constraining I want to
put on something looser and I put on
[ __ ] jean shorts and stuff she's like
that's all you wanted to do so we wound
up going to Jerry's famous deli which is
I'm Beverly don't exist anymore and
stuff and had like that conversation
where everything the person says is
[ __ ] interesting I've never known
anyone like her before she's beautiful
and she worked at USA Today I was very
impressed by that because I was like I
did something at a young age like
Clarkson [ __ ] but she was way younger
and working at USA Today I was like you
you are read by more people than I've
ever [ __ ] been able to reach like
that's a kick-ass job and stuff so I was
kind of way into her and we went to eat
at Jerry's then we went back to her
place and we [ __ ] that night and that
like bonded yes and it was the jacket
and our relationship you know we've been
lugged together we just celebrated 19
years married but we've been [ __ ] it
for thank you
but we've been [ __ ] for twenty years
that's more important than [ __ ] that's
the foundation of the relationship I
wouldn't be married to this [ __ ] but we
weren't [ __ ] that's like that's
that's what I liked about her that stuff
and it all became because of the jacket
so for years throughout our marriage
this jacket is hung in a closet in a bag
never to be taken out again only to be
like Oh remember when I could fit it
into this jacket and [ __ ] and
periodically I'd put it on it wouldn't
meet or anything would be very
frustrating so the other jacket that I
was wearing on Halle weed is way too big
now so I was like oh [ __ ] maybe I'll fit
into the Versace jacket and I tried and
it's like wait this is clownish Liebig
as well so on set they get you thank you
for that
as a Weight Watchers ambassador it's
nice to have clothing that doesn't fit
but when I got to set they were like you
can't wear that you look like David
Byrne and a [ __ ] Talking Heads video
and [ __ ] so they gave me a different
[ __ ] jacket to wear and stuff so but
this is just something I'm wearing to
get home it's weird not to wear a hockey
jersey weird not to have the Hat that's
the other thing I should address my hair
looks [ __ ] fantastic
it's not done by me it's done by Emily
who does my hair and makeup all time
generally when she does my hair it's a
joke because I wear her had all the
[ __ ] time but look one day of the
[ __ ] year when I'm like I require all
your [ __ ] special skills
that's when she did this so like I don't
know if you know or not but like good
general I were a baseball out so people
don't say I had a massive [ __ ] bald
spot in the back of my head but if you
look at this [ __ ] right now
yes sexist sexy oh my god that is the
size it's not [ __ ] it's basically a
toupee and [ __ ] like that she takes it
it's it looks like a yarmulke and it
literally covers my [ __ ] bald spot
and she weaves it in and she does such a
great job it looks magic so I she put in
my [ __ ] hair and stuff she had what
do you think she's like you got cute
hairs like I do have cute hair let me
test it out and I went into the bedroom
and I showed my wife I was like hey
and no lie she was like oh my god like
we were flying we were flying from we
were in Toronto over the weekend we were
flying home and at the airport I bought
a book I bought the book sapiens which
I've heard about many times like Barack
Obama loves the book and [ __ ]
and I was like you know what man it's
been a while since I've read a book this
book seems like it would float my boat
and she had Joe Rogan talked about it as
well I said I think I'm gonna buy this
book and my wife was like you're never
gonna get past page four and I was like
why do you say that she's like because
you never [ __ ] read and I was like I
read a book about Bobby Hull six years
ago
you know I'm do yeah it's [ __ ] time
so I bought the book and start reading
it whatnot and when I was reading it on
the plane she like one point she puts
the book down as like what's up she's
going I just got to tell you I'm not
even joking around she's like you
sitting there reading the book I'm wet
right now you know I know I was like
really that's all a duck fog man I'll be
picking up books left and right and just
waving him in her face and [ __ ]
so when I went in this morning to show
her what we call magic hair and [ __ ] I
walked in i was like hey she was like oh
my god as much as I wanted to [ __ ] you
for reading a book she's like if you
didn't have to go to set right now I'd
[ __ ] your brains out and I was like the
hair she goes it's amazing and [ __ ] I
really missed out on some good [ __ ] by
having a bald spot most of my [ __ ]
life I'll be honest with you man so much
so that like when we were done shooting
the like do you want to take their piece
off and like [ __ ] no I'm a winner today
you know I mean I tell you like standing
next to you with the hair and that
jacket as a former journalist I'd [ __ ]
you right some of that IR porn you see
on pornhub that you like so much man
[ __ ] heaven Ian ivory getting
together and [ __ ] you just can't run
your fingers through my hair because
you'd yanked it right the [ __ ] off maybe
that's the jam yeah that's own ends just
as you're about to [ __ ] you yanked my
toupee off my head
people like us the hottest geekiest porn
I've ever watched fat man on Batman
indeed alright enough of me what have
you been up to nothing that good I went
to the movies one time do you see
anything I did what do you see I saw
Incredibles - oh [ __ ] I mean should we
talk about it now rather then we could
talk about a little bit either that or
we start the show and immediately talk
about it you might as well keep going so
you went how do you know who did you
blow well I had my good hair in battle
[ __ ] it's true man this town is all
about hair what uh how did you get in I
I pulled in a couple of favors because
again former journalist so I said hey my
kids birthday maybe you could like let
me in with the kid and so they did
that's [ __ ] so we got to the premiere
though because I don't have that much
juice left number one though I should
point out you said former journalists
did I not just see you have a byline and
Hollywood Reporter this week I did my
line in Hollywood boy this week it has
been a week on the internet for me so
far yeah what's what was that a ball
about well cuz cuz I'm not sure if you
guys have been paying attention but
Kelly Marie Tran Rose Tico from the last
Jedi pictures she was wonderful she has
the best line in the movie probably
where she says that's how we're gonna
win this for not my [ __ ] money what
we hate but my god it's about to cry
saying it out loud that's how you know
that's a great moment of good line she
said in the theater uh-huh and but when
I try to relate it to people in real
life it doesn't matter what I'm doing I
could be hanging out with a bunch of
dudes or a ragged on each other and [ __ ]
if I was suddenly like hey man you know
what Rose Tico said Atlanta
yes it would be a weird conversation
stopper but when I said it I couldn't
get through cuz I would [ __ ] cry it's
very emotional so uh yes she had a high
point in the movie she had a high point
in the movie and so much of the press
around the movie especially the the
press junket the premiere was her story
because this was her first movie really
and also the first Asian American lead
or a character ever in a Star Wars movie
totally who
couldn't tell was behind makeup like she
was actually out there right of
everybody it's a hearse similar
Cinderella story of the entire thing was
lovely to see and then when people when
the division in the Star Wars fandom
universe
fell between people who loved last Jedi
people hated last Jedi some of those who
hated the last Jedi decided to focus
some of that ire and hate on her oh it's
her fault it's her fault yeah [ __ ]
Rian Johnson's not responsible at all
right Ryan sitting over here Mondays
pause tween y'all Wow he jumped to her
defense I like the entire cast sort of
rallied around her but she became this
sort of the totem of their they're sort
of dislike for the movie and leveling
all kinds of just harassing insults and
which didn't Daisy Ridley take some [ __ ]
on force awakens Daisy Ridley took some
[ __ ] John boyega took some [ __ ] [ __ ] oh
my god when they [ __ ] first showed
the stormtrooper like it's a black
stormtrooper [ __ ] impossible
are you but we moved past that and
started quickly I mean there was still
some dislike for Rey the the idea that
she is a Mary Sue so much so that Daisy
Ridley left the social media at one
point she too backed away because why
would you subject yourself to Burridge's
of hatred in a public forum like why do
that it's not healthy for anybody to
have to do yeah you got to really have
zero self-esteem to like stay on the
internet as much as I do and you get
people like Daisy Ridley they could just
jump off be like oh my god [ __ ] like
real life's way better I'm like no it's
not I'll take your [ __ ] abuse I just
want to be on mean tweets with Jimmy Kim
Hall loved me in any way you choose you
could [ __ ] say our [ __ ] about me
you can [ __ ] my wife I don't care
[ __ ] me the [ __ ] out just give me your
love and that defines the entertainment
business
but Kelly turns out didn't want that and
so she sure deleted most of everything
from her Instagram feed but that's a
shame she shouldn't have to do this she
was enjoying herself at all yeah and so
I wrote a piece just kind of examining
what it means what fandom is by its very
nature hmm and it is an us-versus-them
proposition it always was it was we are
the ones who love this little thing that
nobody else loves and they are the ones
who don't get it kind of tribal very
very like rock together
it's 1972 and nobody likes Star Trek but
us so we're gonna gather in some
Ballroom in hotel and just wear our
costumes and trade our autographs and
you see how it's so [ __ ] sad too
because it began from a good place it
came from a place of like oh man I don't
fit in with anybody else Hey Star Trek
allows me to fit in hey star wars allows
me to fit and now I fit in someplace and
then [ __ ] cut to a couple decades
later like you're not involved you can't
[ __ ] come obviously people have
forgotten at one point they desperately
wanted to be part of something and Star
Wars was the first one to become
mainstream no worse is the first time
you would see oh [ __ ] Mark Hamill is on
The Tonight Show and holy [ __ ] they're
making Yoda underwear and everybody is
under this giant tent to love the thing
but there still has to be of them
there's always got to be of them in
fandom and so what happens is it begins
to turn inwards it begins to find
dividing lines within the fandom you
like a walks you don't like a walks I
don't like people who kind of don't like
Ewoks but I love people who love Ewoks
and whatever like it's finding wages a
lot of stars upon bars kind of totally
like you're just cordoning off ways to
still feel special about the thing you
love fandom back in the when I first
like well I've been a part of it since I
was able to watch TV or movies but like
I became an active part of it on both
sides in the early 90s and the joke then
was always like you know when you go to
comic-con comic-con is filled with a
bunch of people who are like look at
those [ __ ] Star Trek geeks and
they're dressed like stormtroopers you
know like there is a lot of irony like
even within a subgroup they'll find a
way to separate so to separate somebody
out like everybody in all of Hall H
would have gotten
beaten up for liking what they like back
in the real world but you're all
together here but you can still find the
way attic talk [ __ ] about the Twilight
fans because you don't get Twilight like
should we all just love the fact that we
love something that's that's the the the
parent core of what makes us all fans I
was at hall age the year that Twilight
was there at San Diego for the first
time and there was a lot of [ __ ] and a
lot of people like was enough to [ __ ]
could do with anything I - I was on
Holly stage I was like um number one
it's vampires so that has everything to
do with this [ __ ] but number two more
importantly it's [ __ ] girls you
[ __ ] like finally there's some
[ __ ] women here you're gonna chase
him out shut the [ __ ] up I waited my
whole life for this yes start just
starting on your head and being like
yeah I like vampires and Sparkle too
like [ __ ] you won't be alone you won't
die alone like so yeah so so talking
about the fact that Star Wars fandom has
sort of turned in on itself and decided
to like and dislike some things versus
other things and then sub segments of
that fandom have gotten incredibly
virulent and incredibly just awful and
nasty and and seemingly betraying
everything that they loved about Star
Wars to begin with because at one point
a little green puppet tells us anger
leads to the dark side we've all
forgotten or some people have forgotten
that very important lesson it's like
you're allowed to not like something
that's fun you're allowed to have
problems with these movies that's fine
but to take it to such a level to chase
somebody was having the best year of her
life off of the forum for where she was
displaying the best year of her life
feels wrong it feels misguided is beyond
feeling wrong flat out is wrong and it's
just like and what's her crime like
seriously what did she do like I could
point to 10,000 [ __ ] celebrities that
you could harass and feel guilt free
because they [ __ ] deserve it you know
she's not one of those [ __ ] people
man it's like you really want to harass
somebody it's like they pick a
Kardashian you know and I'm not even
condoning that but it's like at least
there you can be like there's something
to say like
I don't know you know in some ways she's
a trailblazer yeah and still she's got
to eat [ __ ] for it which is really
[ __ ] unfortunate you know so it's it
was the piece kind of looking at what
that fandom means and what this fandom
wants like what do Star Wars fans want
from Star Wars is it more like the last
Jedi is it more like solo is it more
like the stuff that we like when we were
nine and 10 and 11 years old which we
are frankly never going to get again
because we're never going to be 9 and 10
at 11 years old
that's the problem you got a lot of
people chasing the dragon man they're
just like oh I want that [ __ ] high
like when I was seven and it's like what
your [ __ ] 48 like you know find
another way have a child [ __ ] do
something that makes people's hearts
sore but like you can't George Lucas
setting himself [ __ ] best there's a
clip on the internet that I goddamn love
cuz you don't think of this man as a
philosopher king by any stretch of the
imagination
you know whenever you see him [ __ ]
talking he's always like Harlock Porky's
like you know just there's no but if you
go to youtube and you enter George Lucas
happiness you will find this amazing 2
to 6 minute clip depending on which one
you choose he was speaking somewhere and
I forget where he's [ __ ] speaking
like a commencement speech yourself some
sort of speech wasn't a graduation but
it was like a gathering of some people
and he spoke about the difference
between happiness and joy and I I swear
to you it's one of the most eloquent
things ever spoken on the subject even
written or spoken that you've ever seen
it's [ __ ] spellbinding this is coming
from the guy who started it all for
heaven's sakes like take a page from
that guy's book man that guy is not a
guy that's out there actively [ __ ]
on things like it's especially Star Wars
like think about it if there's anyone in
the world who could be like I hate the
new Star Wars it's the old Star Wars guy
but he hasn't been that guy he's been
kind of supportive every once in a while
he does a little snipe here there
something like here in here hello Fleck
little ball in there like [ __ ] [ __ ]
you but other than that he's totally
he's freed if I could do it man
I don't know what was microrna bringing
that up I forget I was gonna go
happiness and joy not does enjoy
enjoy yeah you know and so I you know
wrote this piece saying that some Star
Wars fans have done that and then the
Internet has decided that some also
means all and that I'm saying that all
Star Wars fans are hateful and toxic and
awful oh wait wait wait
yeah misinterpreted something from the
internet and you took [ __ ] so there was
a story that you had nothing to do with
and then you wrote a piece gone hey man
we should all just get along and then
people were like [ __ ] you oh yes the
narrative that that's a haiku version of
this narrative that all still holds I
would call I would say that that's
tragic but that's like a [ __ ] Tuesday
on the Internet of torture which is what
it was did you have to go out and defend
yourself I don't really you know it's
it's it's the I thought deep and long
about this subject I wrote a piece on it
that I stand by and people are allowed
to interpret or misinterpret it any way
they please but like getting in there
throwing elbows trying to defend myself
is not going to actually make it any
better nor do I feel like I have to
defend myself so it's like I said a
thing I think it's true it is my opinion
as such I think I defended it pretty
well because I've done this before but
if you agree with me awesome thanks if
you don't I get it fine but it was like
I'm gonna take Monday off the internet
because it was that [ __ ] bad it was
just like you know mentions Palooza of
like and and my new favorite phrase
which is social justice warrior which
we've talked about before yeah which why
aww I mean is an awesome collection of
words and I don't understand how
somebody managed to make it a bad thing
doesn't sound like it's a cool term I
mean look what that sounds metal no like
well it ain't metal yeah but but I bet
you like if there was a poster boy for
to be Jason Momoa and how could that be
[ __ ] bad yeah I dig it [ __ ] god if
Aquaman don't work out you're gonna see
Jason Momoa as the social justice ward
yeah when it comes to fandom I don't
know if you could you could look back on
my career I mean there's [ __ ] I've done
in the movies I've talked about Star
Wars or in clerks - we talked about like
rag Don Lord of the Rings and [ __ ] like
that but always like in good fun I'm not
like us there's nothing in this world
I've never seen a piece of film that
entertainment that made me feel hate in
my [ __ ] heart maybe I never watched
[ __ ] triumph of the will from
beginning to end or something like that
so maybe that would make me feel [ __ ]
like hate my heart but like you know
somebody tells a story I don't like I
just go listen to another [ __ ] story
and there was a time in my life where I
guess I felt it was important for people
to know exactly how I felt about
everything - and I did an interview once
for film threat 1994 man and I [ __ ]
went off unasked-for about this
daredevil movie that Chris Columbus was
gonna write where I was like they're
gonna let the guy that write home alone
write this [ __ ] like [ __ ] him he don't
know daredevil you know so much so that
my agent called me and she goes Chris
Columbus is a client of his agency and I
was like oh I hear he's doing daredevil
and she said you gave some interview on
film threatened you said some really
shitty things about him I was like oh he
read that and she goes yeah and I didn't
think he would [ __ ] see it you know
and I was like oh [ __ ] I guess maybe I
feel a little bad or something she goes
I need you to write him an apology
letter and I was like are you [ __ ]
serious man like I just like left high
school and I thought I was going in the
movie business but it's the same [ __ ]
thing like so I wrote Chris Chris
Columbus an apology letter which was
probably to be honest with you more
facetious than he would have gotten now
like now I'd write him a really elegant
kind of honest apology but back then I
was like I'm so sorry
you should sail the ocean blue up your
own [ __ ] ass buddy
but you know that was boy you know who
was 20 I was like 23 20 24 now I'm you
know I've spent my life a better part of
my life on the internet I got on the
internet with a the view askew website
late 95 so [ __ ] over No yes over 20
years at this point yeah Jesus Christ
over 20 years at this point so I've
learned the subtle art overtime of not
having to share every [ __ ] opinion I
have and honestly go back and listen to
thousands of hours of podcasts that I've
done watch this show from here until the
end of time you rarely see me [ __ ]
on something if ever all right you'll
hear me suck the dick of so many things
that I love and I'll sell it like the
cure for cancer like you [ __ ] can't
live your life without it but if there's
some [ __ ] I don't like
I don't bother talking about it like
that's how I deal with [ __ ] I don't like
I don't talk about if you don't what I'm
here for my friend yeah I read that on
the internet all the time they like it's
nice that Kevin likes everything but
mark is honest
also at Disney show apparently which
that was the other thing that I got a
lot of Disney show loving us Star Wars
because they pay you a lot the Star Wars
it's a Disney show yeah well you know
Star Wars belongs with the Disney so
people think that I am on or Marvel
there's a lot of teats I'm apparently
suckling froggy a lot of that on line
too though you [ __ ] marvel must pay
you a lot of money I was like the other
way around [ __ ] like I I give
them all my money and they entertain the
[ __ ] 15 bucks every three months yeah
[ __ ] plus the teachers bless the [ __ ]
toys plus the time on a therapy couch
going on know what's gonna happen in
Avengers for payment plan totally that
was part of my well number one bully for
you and congrats for writing a [ __ ]
good piece and standing up for somebody
an Incredibles 2 was also awesome
what is it credible Incredibles 2 was
awesome yeah let's [ __ ] how we how did
that happen we retire edibles and then
we derail this oh because we talked
about it was my [ __ ] fault I remember
but anyway back that's beautiful that
you did that let's get back to the
Incredibles yeah I wasn't its listen the
first Incredibles is one of my favorite
movies of all time real is the best
superhero movie I think that's ever been
made yes I would agree with that
hands-down and so this is not the best
superhero movie that's ever been made
okay but it is absolutely part of that
conversation like it does so many things
so [ __ ] well the cast is unbelievable
the action is off the [ __ ] charts
does it feel like since its animation
and since if I remember correctly
they're opening the movie where they
close the last movie yeah does it feel
like any time as past not at all have
like all the voices are still the same
and they're all like still pitch perfect
the animation is just better but it's
not different right you know but it's
it's it's so inventive in so many
different ways The Incredibles contains
one of my favorite action sequences of
all time which is the missile lock
sequence she's like they're children
aboard abort abort abort like it's it is
one of the most intense
for Michelle during I can't you told me
not to damn it don't do what I tell you
to do do what I do gasps oh my god it's
Fannin and we were buddies spike and I
repeat we are buddies spike there are
children up or and mr. incredible is
like like on the [ __ ] torture thing
going no my children you have seen this
movie a few times and it kind of well
done man [ __ ]
I love the missile lock sequence
apparently not as much as you
so my bar for this movie was high but
you're saying it clears the bar it
clears the bar it's not as good as the
first few things are but it's still it's
an amazing time it's Brad bird man I
just says I'm playing back from Toronto
and I spent the flight back watching
three animated movies I watched brave
which I had never seen absolutely loved
then I watched Toy Story 3 again
Schindler's toy box and and I hadn't
seen it since I saw it and what an
emotional journey that was and on a
plane to where you just automatically is
clutching my wife the whole time like
and she's reading her book I'd given up
on my book four pages in that's
predicted and I was just [ __ ] grossed
in the movie and then the last one I
watch was they offered Iron Giant and I
haven't seen I hadn't seen Iron Giant in
a red hot minute and my god it more than
held up if anything you sit there it's
beautiful traditional 2d animation on
one hand you're like [ __ ] they should do
this in the current style they totally
could but being that it's set in the 50s
it kind of like still works and and you
know it's I grew up on 2d animation so
watching that is like it's like watching
a chappie a happy childhood to some
degree but the story itself I remember
all the high points but I had I forgot
the tail end so in my version of the
Iron Giant Superman and then he dies and
then everyone's sad credits and then
[ __ ] I was bawling in my [ __ ] seat
my wife is like she pulls my headphones
off she goes stop watching cartoons
you couldn't help it out so far get
emotional and then all of a sudden
there's their like the PS scene where
the screw comes on his went on his
window windowsill and then takes off and
then and then I remember his I go oh
he's putting himself back together like
they're gonna be friends again and that
I was sitting there going well what
happens to the statue do they leave it
up because they put up a statue like in
memory of the Iron Giant but if he comes
back and he's like why he just eats it
he's like ah ha ha they're like you
[ __ ] prick oh my [ __ ] Bildad but
he's a master storyteller bradbury that
movie's wonderful The Incredibles is why
should give him a tattoo he he took over
yeah it started to somebody else's and
he did it and I watched the scene from
that and watch the whole thing I do love
it but I never enough times the plane
was landing but I watched The Critic
scene Peter O'Toole plays the critic and
does that lovely speech about [ __ ]
celebrating the new breathtaking one
wonderful [ __ ] piece of writing and
stuff and that's Brad Bird so this guy
is absolute [ __ ] magician I even
liked his Mission Impossible movie and
stuff like that I loved
Tomorrowland I was one of the few people
that was waving a flag for her people
like go [ __ ] yourself oh so you [ __ ]
yourself
I believe in tomorrow wonderful [ __ ]
flick man so I think this dude is like
truly truly truly they should they
should hand him Superman I mean if
there's anybody who could handle that
it's [ __ ] brother [ __ ] great idea
oh my god
I wish you were running Hollywood [ __ ]
man is there a killer sequence maybe not
as killer has missile lock sequence but
is there something in there that you're
like oh [ __ ] wait till the scene yeah
yeah
there's there's a really I'm out of
spoiling okay there is there is a
family-centric scene that that is
inventive and logical and it all makes
sense and they set it up and they pay it
off and and it's not quite that
heartbreaking but it is like peril
averted by heroic deeds here's a
question shoot
Pixar when we think of classic Pixar we
don't think of the sequels we think of
you know the movies and stuff but Rick's
our has now been in the sequel business
for a minute or two so they've done a
couple thousand cars
these had done two monsters inks have
they done any that they've done three
toy story so it stays all they've all
worked this I think a couple Nemo's and
[ __ ] so on that scale in terms of a
Pixar sequel where is it amongst the
sequels they've done so far with Toy
Story 3 being the high bar yeah I think
it is just below Toy Story 3 oh that's
good yeah really [ __ ] that's really good
it's really good
all right so it's gonna make all the
money yeah they're projecting like 140
million dollar opening weekend look the
highest animated opening of all time
beautiful thing is like they keep making
those [ __ ] movies long after like
everyone is in in them has passed away
long after the audience has passed away
there'll be new audience and [ __ ] like
just get sound-alike she can make
Incredibles movies forever though never
get older and they'll never dies just
like cocoon at this point they could
digitize all of that voice work and just
use that to break down the phonetic
sounds and just build new dialogue
totally like Hello mr. incredible people
like my god that sounds naturally I'm
alright man so Incredibles 2 thumbs up I
saw ocean's 8 oh [ __ ] you saw hor the
show it is like you know like just going
to the park with friends I'm kind of
hanging out and everybody's dressed real
nice and what do we do it's like we
opening credit of friends it's it's
again lots of ways it is just I'm
hanging out with lovely people who were
doing that are having fun I'm kind of
having fun too
it is it is low stress and that's
perfectly fine it is you know it is like
that I remember the oceans movies 11:00
is my favorite 13 is pretty good 12 is
just like Brad Pitt and George Clooney
hanging out with their friends for a
while and there might be a movie
involved we're not clear at least here
there's a movie involved really yeah
this is the first one that's not a
Soderbergh version correct who directed
Gary Ross he directed CSUN and he wrote
this as well yes I know Danny ocean is
referenced in the trailer he is is he
referenced throughout the movie in like
three or four places right
yeah like he's mentioned but never seen
except for like in a picture are there
any secret cameos that we haven't heard
about
not that well again oh there's one
there's one there apparently wasn't Matt
Damon cameo that got cut is that right
that would have tied him together yeah I
like to scare Linus I think that was a
surgery what what when when you left the
theater did you feel as my friend Dan
Etheridge whose works on iZombie and
needed Veronica Mars back in the day we
went to see what was it
catch me if you can
me him and my wife and we came out and I
was like what you think and he gave the
best review I ever heard for a movie
like that he goes you know what man
sometimes you just want to be swaddled
in the warm bosom of a Hollywood movie
so it sounds like that's very much that
oh look everybody looks great they're
all having fun like the high stuff is
pretty cool and the fashion is amazing
and I've never been to the Met Ball know
where other go to the Met Ball but now
wouldn't know what that is right
and it's just hey cool answer question
thank you very much like it was like
going to Google but more entertaining
totally that's what you want out of
emotion baby any much $15 for that okay
that's worth it is that all you've seen
that is all I've seen I have some TV I
need to catch up where they need to
watch cloak and dagger the first yeah
but seeing billboards everywhere yeah
first two episodes are out I still
haven't seen Cobra Kai which I really
want to watch the first two episodes
that I absolutely loved it yeah all
right but I haven't obviously not enough
to keep going not enough to pay for you
yeah they were like you know you gotta
pay I'm like [ __ ] you no but I will
actually as the one thing that I said
you know what I will join you to bread
for this because I was enjoying the [ __ ]
I was insanely well [ __ ] done and
entertaining and kind of like oh my god
we live in a world where you can do this
you could do a [ __ ] sequel The Karate
Kid that is not daniel-san centric like
now they're just looking at the bad guy
what's [ __ ] next man it's like I'm
the person that built this Halloween
costume remember he's in the tub and the
first one and [ __ ] follow my [ __ ]
adventure but good for them I think
that's cool I think they should do that
same thing with the Bad News Bears
like they should take Tatum O'Neal and
they should take Jackie Earle Haley and
let them be the coaches of two Little
League teams now like and do it on
YouTube bread so it's like uh whoever
wants it'll watch it and you watch those
numbers [ __ ] hit it be nuts dude I
mean not for nothing but you just
I hope YouTube calls you tomorrow it is
I would watch that [ __ ] show I don't
think that's gonna have YouTube calls me
tomorrow they'll be like will you take
down the video of you and your dick out
I don't care how many hits are good all
right we're done talking about that [ __ ]
we're talking about that means it's time
to segue into the newsman mark barnard
and marvelous Marc Maron ladies and
gentlemen does the heavy lifting on this
show he goes the [ __ ] Internet and
takes other people's work and then tells
it to us and by the way of the news give
it up for Marc in the news I like to
call it I like to call it mama birding
the news yes which is I'll just kind of
chew it up for you and then spit it back
into your face did you catch it awesome
if not then I'm sorry
oh I'll [ __ ] catch a bill coming yeah
yeah get it get me so um did you pay
attention to the DC entertainment news
of the last couple of days yes oh my god
that's the news is so shocking I'm gonna
stop writing yeah it was [ __ ] I guess
it wasn't shocking but at the same time
it was a huge development our good
friend Geoff Johns who has been in
charge of many things over the last
[ __ ] couple decades including when I
first met Jeff he was working for dick
Donner and he knew I was big you know
geek fan and stuff like that I think I
was about let me see I had the kid so it
was 99 I think the first time I
interacted with him he was working for
Richard Donner and he was like I've got
the uncut footage of Superman running
the gauntlet in Superman the footage
that got cut because they were working
on doing like Superman the ultimate cut
so he sent me and stuff it was awesome
we became friends he went on he was
become a writer at DC Comics redefined
many of their characters made that flash
character what it is today when I was
Barry Allen was just very [ __ ] fast
he had yellow hair and that was it that
is all the backstory had Geoff Johns if
you like anything about the flash it
probably has something to do with Geoff
Johns he's the one that gave him the
backstory of his mom getting killed and
all that [ __ ] really wonderful writer
and so much so that eventually he became
editor-in-chief the comic division he
was he was the chief creative officer he
vented went beyond just comics into the
features well I mean his name's all over
the Berlanti verse stuff so he's
co-creator on the flash I think he's
producer on arrow and some of the other
ones I know they get a lot to do with
the Titan show and Doom Patrol which is
spinning out of the Titans show but for
the last few years he's been the guy
overseeing the movie division so DC
extended universe of whatever they're
calling at the DCE you he's been the
person who and whether it's fair or not
the shortest and to describe him has
always been he's the Kevin Feige of the
DC movies right that's not exactly a
hundred percent accurate yeah I mean he
goes not successful yes fair enough day
yes he didn't have the sort of sweeping
power that Feige has over the moral
universe yeah and which well earned like
earned by the success that he had with
Iron Man and stuff like that but yes it
seems that Kevin is the string-puller he
gets I mean he's you know he's got don't
don't get me wrong like those directors
and and those writers definitely
contribute you got somebody and
contributing big bad ways but you've got
somebody who's telling one long game
story in a way that I haven't seen
anybody work in a major studio [ __ ]
ever you look back maybe the closest
thing you can point to or the broccolis
the people that like own the James Bond
movies but yeah because their names on
every one but they're not creatively
involved like Kevin is Kevin's plotted
out these last 10 years of Marvel movies
so Jeff didn't have that quite well
reported up a corporate chain he still
was not quite left to steer the ship as
he would have done but he was the
closest they had to that yes and like
I'm certainly not I'm trying to do this
delicately and politically if there are
stuff that you liked about those movies
chances are that was Jeff yeah he had
something to do with the
things that fans were responding to yes
came from him because he is first and
foremost a fan yes and a wonderful
[ __ ] writer so that being said as we
all know those movies have not been
nearly as successful as the as the
Marvel movies and stuff and the last one
they put out was Justice League which I
guess not my words but in the words of
the press it's considered a
disappointment I'm sure you can find
some people just save and worse than
that and stuff so it was only a matter
of time before head started to roll and
heads have now fully started to roll
Diane dam Nelson that was the head of DC
entertainment she was on a leave of
absence for about six months and she
just announced that she's leaving the
company entirely when she left Jeff also
decided to transition out of his role as
the chief creative officer and head of
DC entertainment to a producer writer
role and which honestly is like
fantastic for him yes okay that's what
he does he writes very well hopefully
they'll let him direct as well so heed
this superhero [ __ ] is burrowed deep in
his skin like a tick like he's one of
the true believers man he really he's
done a lot for the medium on the page
and then also helping to bring it to the
screen and been very successful with the
TV run and stuff like that like all
those Berlanti shows are fantastic and
keep the true beating heart of comic
books alive more so than those movies
have done the DC movies in the last few
years so I'm happy for him but I don't
know if that's a is that a kick in the
pants or is that him gone and over this
I think it's him deciding like I'm going
to leave now before maybe they edge me
out and are taking a like listen they're
offering me a producer deal on the lot
where I've got a company and he's
writing the Green Lantern Corps movie
he's got a co-writer credit on Wonder
Woman too whatever they're calling it VW
84 you know and you'll still have
something to do with all the TV stuff
but he's and he's writing a new Shazam
comic book he's got a new imprint called
the killing zone I think for DC he's
gonna be fine he's done pretty well for
himself
and Gimli is taking over as the chief
creative officer of DC comic now what
was Jim's position prior to this
co-publisher he and Dan DiDio shared the
publisher title so he's kind of moving
out of the comics divisions into the
movie division
I mean he's he's staying co-publisher
okay but he's now going to help oversee
a lot of that larger creative story
thrusts ideas stuff that I think Jeff
was doing before do you think they will
alright so Jim's replacing Jeff and he's
still holding his other job so that's
the only real big change I think will
they replace Dai announce anything maybe
later in the interim I think they're
just kind of streamlining the whole
corporate strategy structure whatever
that she came from Harry Potter world
yeah she was in brand management and
sherry successful with that and they
were like hey Harry Potter's kind of
like comic books and so somebody there's
all these brooms surely somewhere up the
chain somebody [ __ ] felt like that
was a good match and stuff and it wasn't
a horrible match but those are those
properties are not nearly exactly I just
got to make sure that one lady over
there is happy yeah you good
not so much brand management as JK
management do you need a new pillow you
okay yeah she's like I don't need a
pillow I sleep on a billion dollar bed
and I don't mean a cause a billion I
mean the bed is full of a billion
dollars tempur-pedic made this special
from me yeah she's like did I tell you I
was married once what an idiot he is all
right so that's fantastic that's good
news for Jeff yeah good news I think
ultimately for whatever the DC movies
are going forward but going forward is a
little weird because they seem to making
a lot of Joker movies and I don't know
who's asking for all these Joker there
are since we last spoke they've
announced 96 Joker movies it's like a
deck filled with Joker's what is what's
the latest Joker movie count right now
what about well there's two for sure
which are Phillips is making the Todd
Phillips Dark One that's not part of the
DC extended Roger stand alone with
Martin Scorsese producing right and
potentially Joaquin Phoenix starring as
the Joker right I mean that's all of
that is just like could you imagine if
I'd said that to you 20 years ago you're
like would you read that the pages of
wizard what if and [ __ ]
but that is a truth that's a reality and
it would be like Joe Pesci's gonna play
The Joker oh my god what am i clown do I
amuse you well technically yes all right
so there's that Joker movie and the
second Joker movie is now what the a
Jared Leto Leto Joker picture the one
everyone wants well yeah the best ten
minutes of Suzette's grand just writ
large here's my feeling and you know
bear in mind I'm always mr. positive
give him another shot at it you know and
I'm saying like you know he wasn't the
absolute give him another shot at it man
like it's a wonderful actor he's a guy
that's won an Oscar and stuff like you
know maybe he's seen this one and he's
like you know there's some [ __ ] I could
do differently and it might be kind of
interesting and stuff all right you know
I'm all for look they can give me as
many Joker movies they want I'm
definitely paying to see each one and
and I'd be happy honestly it sounds
stupid but if they gave me a joker movie
every year I'd be there in line to
[ __ ] pay for it if they gave me a
Batman movie every six months I would
[ __ ] go out and see in the theater
and see it I like these characters I
like these stories so they can keep
pumping as much as they want and if this
is like yeah this is the serious Joker
movie and this is the one that like is
within our continuity I'm totally fine
with that
ah don't [ __ ] on this man we're living
this amazing time where we have not one
but two Joker movies and I don't think
you should have any Joker movies because
I don't want to joke a movie because the
Joker is not a character the Joker is a
weather system the Joker is you don't
need to know where the storm came from
you don't need to know why the storm is
gonna land on the [ __ ] eastern
seaboard you just need to know that the
storm is coming and look at the damage
it does I don't want to humanize the
Joker that's not what I'm here for I
don't want his story I don't care like I
kind of feel like the Joker
but what are the genius moves of the
Marvel Universe was figuring out that
the Hulk does not need his own movie the
Hulk is better but that was the
necessity being the mother of invention
they loved to do their own Hulk movie
whatever they got a share it with the
universe share with Universal so if we
can't do that maybe he's just going to
be a character he's going to be a flavor
of spice in this ongoing story that
makes things better to the point where
you cannot do a buddy picture with you
know the hulking [ __ ] thorn it's
amazing yes I would watch a Harley Quinn
vs. the Joker movie actually like he's
the antagonist and she's the hero and
you understand what it's like to be a
scorned woman who was emotionally abused
to watch revenge
I would watch that movie it's not
[ __ ] fair for you to write better
movies on this podcast man like they
can't compete with that that's a good
[ __ ] idea because they're making a
birds of prey or Gotham ladies or Harley
Quinn movie and yeah and doing two joker
movies why not just [ __ ] yeah like I
just I don't I don't want it I want the
version of the Joker that does never
tell us where he came from that was the
beauty of the Dark Knight it was like
here's a guy who's got nine origin
stories all of them are lies we don't
know where he's from we just know that
he's an agent of chaos and he's going to
make everything worse for this hero you
know I don't want him to be the hero of
his story just don't that bashes me
maybe we're gonna get one of these every
year do you hear all the silence in this
room the rest of us are like slowly
stepping away from me I'm okay with it
man I'll take all of it because at the
end of the day like it's [ __ ] that I
wouldn't have seen in a previous
lifetime I there was a time I just like
oh my god if they would just do a movie
about this or have this character or
anything we live in a rich time I look
at it like I used to look at comic books
sometimes you read something that's
[ __ ] amazing sometimes you read
something that's pedestrian sometimes
you read absolute [ __ ] [ __ ] but
the more chances they have more bites at
the Apple they get better the chances
are that they're gonna make some cool
[ __ ] so I'm like make them all let God
sort him out yeah I will also say though
that the x-men got this [ __ ] East had
ever got when Wolverine was in nineteen
books a month which they did for a long
time because he was the character
everybody loved
so here's Wolverine in the New Mutants
Wolverine in the x-men Wolverine the
x-men starring Wolverine Wolverine the
New Avengers and
revengeance would like so much
saturation of the one thing never makes
any one of those things stand out but I
mean batting average that's better than
more pitches you take I suppose but at
some point you just want to like do do
it good do it once awesome if the bars
gonna be higher for them on a joker
movie uh because you know and not
because like all we have our
expectations good because of Heath
Ledger of naturally there's that but the
other people will take that role from
now until the time I die so you just
live up to you expect the fact that
sooner or later somebody else will the
high bar is the Joker is an agent of
chaos and if you're gonna make him the
main character in your story I guess
that kind of technically makes him an
antihero of sorts
Deadpool did it expertly twice so can
they come even close to [ __ ] dead bull
if I was making the Joker movie I would
be not trying to [ __ ] do a kind of
insightful piece into the character of
the Joker like you said who needs to
[ __ ] know do what they did like take
a page at Deadpool's book make it fun
interactive he could play with the
[ __ ] camera he's crazy because you
could do [ __ ] anything you want so
don't give us backstory give us [ __ ]
like an experience that you walk away
going [ __ ] man that'd be amazing that's
my thoughts alright moving on to
something else one of my favorite movies
as a kid it was it was the first car
movie ever shown the theater
arachnophobia yeah it it's still it
haunts me living in the suburbs when you
know like uses the [ __ ] shower and
then you see like a spider on the roof
on the ceiling and you're like I gotta
kill a [ __ ] spider now because if not
it's gonna come down between my tits and
almost kill me this is because the thing
I saw in [ __ ] arachnophobia that
movie petrified me at 14 years old are
you sure that came from arachnophobia
not from a real-life experience I had a
different realize I was staying in a
guest house in when I first came out
here to work for The Hollywood Reporter
like $500 a month guest house is so much
rebuilt garage and I'm in their shower
which was like you know there's cedar
blocks and [ __ ] like just pipes run
from the wall it was not in any way
hermetically seal it was a garage with
like a roof put on it and
holes and [ __ ] I'm in the shower and
gecko had climbed in the [ __ ] garage
on the pipe on the [ __ ] shower head
and fell on my head shampooing my head
right so like my eyes are closed and
it's soap everywhere and I can't and so
like I'm naked covered in soap and
there's a lizard splashing around at the
bottom of this bathroom and I killed it
he was just trying to sell you some
[ __ ] insurance man and I killed it in
the worst way possible how I out of the
shower I turned off the cold water and I
just turned up the hot water I'm a
monster you guys I'm the worst and this
will be the last episode as I just
learned that my friend has the
characteristics all the characteristics
of a [ __ ] psycho killer why would you
do that
I don't even kill flies I catch a fly
with a [ __ ] cup and I put a paper
under and I'm bringing outside and I'm
like be free because I can't make a
[ __ ] fly a damn Skippy can't make a
gecko and I'm relatively sure you can
either so the fact that fact that you
just drive one you got a lot of making
up to do I got personal space issues man
apparently I'll stay over here from now
on
lest I wind up you not salted to death
in your [ __ ] shower if you and I are
together other [ __ ] has gone wrong did
you got to take the good hair oh why do
you bring up arachnophobia because it's
getting a remake oh it is I mean I guess
you couldn't [ __ ] do that fairly
easily it's not like the title is what's
the most thing other than your personal
experience it's really the most
memorable part of it James Wan that was
like [ __ ] no James whoa I've heard
of him he's very good
Wow so it might actually be scary
- like the last one was a little bit
goofy I know you seemed terrified by I
mean was that the one that had John
Goodman he's the spider killer yeah yeah
little ivy
I love Goodman but that is definitely a
little on the goofy side that movie this
one they could do a real badass version
really [ __ ] make the jaws of spiders
man but jaws movie the jaws of Spider
movies that's what I guess I said the
jaws of spiders which is a good title
for that movie really write that [ __ ]
down anybody at a shorter was James Wan
friend that's it what's the studio he
used I thought it was Disney last time I
[Music]
touched on yeah yeah so now it's gonna
be one room that's gonna be one of
interesting right on I'll see that man
he's talented let's see
Matthew Vaughn is building a Kingsman
universe he already did that there's two
movies there's two numbers there's two
movies the third one whether it's
calling the third one hold on I have it
here in my note stolen from the internet
hold on hold on
Kingsman the great game that's the the
third in the canopy and a thermal
achieve which would a look at the spy
organization at the turn of the 20th
century there is also statesman spin-off
I think they were gonna do with Channing
Tatum and Joe bridges they want to do a
TV show about the Kingsmen and he's also
she's all in on the kids all in on the
[ __ ] Kingsman he's got his James Bond
and he wants as many movies apparently
that first James I like the second one
to be the first one that's [ __ ]
sequence in the church is stellar
she's blind all that good whole movies
really enjoyable like you snuck up on me
I was like I had no idea I would like
this movie as much as I did and he's
also planning to reboot kick-ass oh
that's smart
yeah totally do that totally kick-ass
and hit girl I think I'm also gonna get
new movies I just finished my hit girl
miniseries not so long ago and sent it
to your friend and my Mark Miller and he
seemed very pleased I was very happy
with it and stuff I'd love it if they
chose that to go with but it's
predicated on the last one more than
anything
I think they're doing a reboot probably
wouldn't be the case right but I enjoyed
[ __ ] writing that character was a
blast I think they can go far me totally
redo kick ass didn't they in the comics
they did a female kick-ass at one point
yeah so you could totally do that by
name and hit boy crossover and [ __ ]
alright I'm not meant for that he's
talented I like all the [ __ ] he's done
he's got a great eye I remember I think
I've talked about on this show like my
agent we share the same agent and I was
over in London time he's like Matthew my
clients got this movie kick-ass I was
like oh I know the comic book you guys
will you go watch it and like maybe give
him some notes and [ __ ] and I was like
oh yeah because that's what every
director wants you know he goes no he's
just he doesn't know the space as well
as you do the comic book space I guess
and so's Akari and I went and watched
the movie and then afterwards talk to
him blew him up about it go oh my god
that was so good by the way
but then I gave him like I was like you
know you could honestly the front of it
is kind of chunky so like you could take
out like just air and some of the deader
jokes may probably pull out like 6
minutes from the first 15 minutes alone
and as I said that I watched this dude
go from polite like who are you to like
get the [ __ ] out of here like and then
finally I was like or do nothing and he
did and it made a lot of money so [ __ ]
me did your agent have to ask you to
write another letter of apology yeah
Gavin you've insulted the other director
he should have apologized to me my
[ __ ] agent I was like don't ever make
me do that again he was like what you
know comic books I was like he doesn't
give a [ __ ] you know but I look forward
to seeing that I flex have been really
[ __ ] good he's wonderful visual
storyteller and he started as the
producer for what's his [ __ ] what's his
name
Guy Ritchie yeah so he was Guy Ritchie's
guy and then one day he was like [ __ ]
that I'm my own man and he started
making movies almost [ __ ] self I'll do
a layer cake i'ma bake a little [ __ ]
cake that is the worst British accent
I've ever heard I was going specifically
cockney with that [ __ ] I was I was all
[ __ ] no knee
cuz I don't bend that [ __ ] what else we
got our last piece of news - we'll segue
into the next part of our the exciting
part of the show this is why I came
tonight [ __ ] the news I came for what's
after the news but uh Avengers infinity
war has officially crossed a two billion
dollar mark oh that that makes me so
happy because I'm responsible for 1
billion myself I'm a part of that story
um yeah man [ __ ] if there ever was a
movie that deserved it talk about the
[ __ ] slow game and long con 10 years
you waited for that movie and it spits
deserves to make all the money it's
[ __ ] making it so it puts it into
number four just behind closed - force
awakens it's is that 2 billion and 0.06
whatever the [ __ ] does they have a good
really good shot it's gonna at some
point eclipse force awakens to be the
number three Wow and then Titanic is 2
point 1 billion and then avatar is 2.7
billion so those so avatar 2.1 is the
uncatchable 1 yeah i mean you're not a
titanic - what is it - 7 to 10 occurs to
one avatar is to seven what was force
awakens 2.0 6 billion Wow oh so they'll
definitely get to Avatar no you don't
think so never oh it's two point not
avatar they'll definitely get to Titanic
don't ever get to force awakens there
there's a shot then it will get to
Titanic but no one will ever - nobody's
gonna touch and it certainly isn't going
to be avatar - yeah I mean unless in
Avengers 4 they kill everybody the only
way avatar 2 makes as much as avatar 1
is all the [ __ ] people from Avengers
infinity war show up in Avatar
they all [ __ ] disappeared and went to
cat world and [ __ ] like that and black
panther was like I'm in charge all right
well I guess we've done with the news we
going with the news oh [ __ ] that's all
the news that's fit to print ladies and
gentlemen which brings us normally to
the Q&A part of the show but brings us
first tonight to the reason most of us
over here we got very lucky we got
[ __ ] quality top-shelf gifts tonight
ladies gentleman is all because of mr.
mark Barnard when you marvel at what
happens over the course of the rest of
the evening and [ __ ] know that it's all
because of Mark Barnard give it up for
Mark Bernardo oh come on and with that I
will turn over introductions of our very
special guests to mr. mark Barnard and
go yes we have two people in this house
who are responsible for billions of
dollars of gross who were responsible
for dreams coming true
or responsible for he was my best friend
so was I that's right Donald Trump is
here ladies we have Christopher Markus
and Stephen McFeely the writers of every
Captain America movie that you love give
it up for thank yous infinity war
[Applause]
please get on your [ __ ] feet scum and
villainy you've got to give the writer
stone this is a great privilege and a
great honor we have said many times on
this show we blown you guys up even if
we never did it with your name sometimes
we're like those [ __ ] dudes whoever
wrote that they're good for us to be
able to talk to you guys and have you
here in this setting is really [ __ ]
special as I've said a few times on the
podcast you're two of my favorite
[ __ ] working writers telling stories
that I passionately care about to the
point where like I get so invested in
them I've missed my daughter growing up
give a [ __ ] because because my real
emotions are with my real family the
fake people in the Marvel movies and
stuff you what you guys have done and
built is nothing short of amazing and I
think it was Mark who maybe pointed it
out to me the first time that you did
all the Captain America's is that
correct that is right that is true
[Applause]
there's a zillion [ __ ] places we
could go and and the one place we're not
gonna go ladies and gentlemen is to try
to get rid of out of them about Avengers
four there's no point I honestly don't
want to [ __ ] know it's one of the few
look living through the heart attack the
only reason I did it was to see infinity
war so you I don't want no [ __ ]
spoilers I want to live to the next
movie as well and discover it for myself
so we won't be diving and trying to pull
details out of my stuff what we get to
do is talk to a couple people who built
help build the universe that a lot of us
live and play in our stories my
grandmother would sit around watch young
and the restless' all the time should be
like I'm watching my stories my stories
as an adult are these movies and the
stories that you guys have told and it's
a high bar because I've loved Marvel
stories ever since I was a kid reading
them in the pages and you guys have
found a way to take those stories that
have been told over the courses of
decades and distill them into like to
our adventures that capture the flavor
the spirit the feeling of cracking open
sometimes those movies are so [ __ ]
authentic I smell old paper watching
those movies that's about the highest
piece of praise that I could [ __ ]
give working filmmaker today let me ask
you this when you step up to the plate
for something like infinity war where
there's been a line of [ __ ] flicks
prior to this a line of expectation and
whatnot how do you even begin how does
it start
does it start with you - does it start
with Feige does it start with where does
it begin it's this one started with us
in that they said it's infinity war it's
thin house put anybody wanting it we're
too busy because cabin is always putting
out a fire he's putting out the fire
that's going to come out in two weeks
all right so he at that let at that
stage he has no
time and that's like I don't care on all
of these we sort of start as the
research and development team to start
so like on that when we were just
starting to shoot civil war so you know
as you know like first two hours of the
day maybe you need the writer and the
rest of day you don't need us so you
know we went to the office and just
started reading comics and by the end of
that summer we had sort of had this
large manifesto of like you're all the
ways you could do this some of them made
exclusive let's talk about it but we
just started writing down the names of
everyone who was still alive in all the
movies or who had been referenced in all
the movies and stuck him along with that
there there's your story the walls the
walls were cool right so like we get
back from Civil War and we spent four
months in a conference room that just
has movie one on one wall movie two on
the other wall and then all these little
like baseball cards with everyone who is
still alive in the universe right and
then we just sort of move them around
like that would be interesting wouldn't
it be great if rocket and Groot and Thor
all spent you know several scenes
together yes Chuck you know and for a
while it was gonna be all live Tyler and
Sharon Carter that's right
it's still like no Liv Tyler's name it's
just Betty
mine Benedict is most of us play how you
make your living we've gotta go would it
be great if I could Falcon on this one
more if I can do in this [ __ ] yeah and
you guys do it they like here's millions
of dollars it is the dream of every fan
to sit there and play with the big toys
no it's ridiculous
yeah it's a crazy sandbox and it was we
like when we made the first cab there
was no indication that there would be a
two of anything and when they cast
Sebastian Stan we went Oh he'd be a cool
Winter Soldier but they're never gonna
[ __ ] make them
[Laughter]
so like it really is ridiculous now that
everything you can put your finger on
you can go you know that could come out
in two years
first avenger when did you guys crack
what that story was going to be when did
you realize that you had the weigh in to
that character because captain america
had been for a very long time scene is
like too much of a boy scout too
goody-goody like how do you deliver so
much pure idealism and heroism in a
world where cinema doesn't feel like
it's ready for that yeah yeah we i took
us a little while but we figured out can
we probably said this before you know
you don't need to give cap a dark night
of the soul particularly in his origin
movie right cap is going to be steady
and he's gonna change the world around
him
so that you don't want to be a movie
that feels like it's made in the forties
but it's gonna have a lot to do with the
40's because it feel like a Gary Cooper
movie in a lot of ways so once we sort
of landed on that that means that you
know you tell a very specific origin
story and again we're given a lot
particularly in that we're given more in
that one than any other one right you
it's gonna be the Red Skull they handed
us a cosmic cube you know and we knew we
had to put him in the ice at the end so
you have a lot of markers yeah what's up
to us is you know his character and
structure you know when do you when you
separate him from Bucky you know like in
the comics they all kind of go down at
the same time it doesn't help us at all
you know you give it it becomes it ended
back to when you you know make up a
train and thank us stuff and we had we
had actually been talking about could
you make a period superhero movie could
you make a movie that took place when
these characters actually came out like
a 1932 Batman and then we found out that
Marvel wanted to do a period cap because
we would have never gone after a
modern-day captain because it's
ridiculous you know and he has to start
in the 40s is the only period where you
could justify looking like that
but once you start in there you can take
them anywhere but it can't be for ten
minutes at the beginning of the movie
and spend the rest of the time chasing
you know gang members one of my single
favorite movie moments of the past 20
years is when cap dives on the grenade
like oh my god
blood that it's the perfect
encapsulation of what makes that guy
tick at what point in the process
did you realize like this we're gonna do
this scene and we know it's gonna work
until the truth about them no well I
think we were looking for the moment
that he was tested and I think I want to
say Joe Johnston may have said maybe
they I saw it some in another movie show
just and said stole it from something
like there's some old war movie where a
guy jumps on a grenade and doesn't go
off but I don't remember the name of it
so we stole it yeah there was a hole
when we needed something like that we
needed the thing that that cemented say
the rivalry between we probably had a 15
minute montage at the beginning you know
in the first draft yeah but when you're
when you're in the room and you're like
we had a hole and suddenly the grenade
thing comes up are you like oh my god
this is our character moment yeah I mean
you know when things are gonna you know
we're working on something now and we're
just beating our head against the wall
because that moment hasn't come to us
where you go it's obviously a movie
that's in the movie you know you have
moments like that when you're writing
what happens this is definitely yeah
[Music]
sorry wrong not about the movie moments
give us one example though of like from
infinity war when you guys are writing
real like I don't care what I was this
definitely blinds up Thord lands with
rocket and Groot on his shoulder
[Applause]
because the whole thing is built up for
that I've imagined you guys sitting
there after you finished writing that
just looking back at each other and be
like we deserve to jerk off and this is
movie magic what is that here and this
is my question like he brought up an
excellent [ __ ] point
you guys took a character that that I
didn't ever really care for he's a
background character the best I ever
enjoyed him I think was when Frank
Miller used him in the background of a
daredevil run or something like that
like I liked his Boy Scout portrayal of
him which was very much like his Boy
Scout portrayal of Superman over in dark
9 so but generally I was not a cat
person by any stretch of the imagination
I had to pick a Boy Scout it was
probably Superman so going into First
Avenger I was just like look I'll see it
because I love comic book movies but
like I don't have a high guard regard
for Captain America you guys changed
that you guys and and the directors and
of course Chris Evans as well the depth
at performance humanized a character
gave him soul and made him one of my
favorite comic book characters of all
time that came from your renditions of
the character if somebody had told me
hey man like you know you guys are
screenwriters [ __ ] so any job that comes
down the pike particularly one that's
like that big is a job worth looking at
but if somebody told me hey man we'll
give you Captain America I would have
been like oh really yeah like Captain
America man can I have [ __ ] on I'm
not spider-man or some [ __ ] when you
guys found out you had Captain America
really yes or you were like oh [ __ ] this
is homework no no we checked
well we chased it did you really for
sure we had uh let's see we sort of got
fired off the third Narnia wait wait
we have to address that do that thrown
out of Narnia [ __ ]
apparently you can't shoot oh there's
one way back in right I don't know if
you saw that movie apparently you can't
show Fonz [ __ ] I thought it was good
because that leaves Bend weird well
thought out it was so wait you lost so
we we had done the first three Narnia's
right and that third one was troubled
and and the writers good one on strike
and they called it hey when the strike
is over don't come back okay fine and so
we had nothing to do you know try to
look for a job
and we spent all year sort of saying no
to it stars a 13 year old girl in the
magical world mystery well we sort of
want to do all something else and iron
man came out and made it clear that they
were gonna make a whole run of stuff
including a period Captain America movie
and we went oh we should get that and we
had to spend all of 2008 say from the
summer on convincing them that we were
the right guys in that and you know and
it took a while the price today right
away they were looking guy said Narnia
get the [ __ ] over exactly there were
more like you're the guys who get Narnia
get the [ __ ] over there
what and so how long was the waiting
present and what is what do you have to
hand in sample scenes how does one get a
job that big I mean well you sit and
talk to them for a long time and then I
think we beat out an outline of some
sort but they liked but they had
obligations to other writers and they
actually went with them but they've got
more time to make a deal then came back
around it's not no I don't know who they
were
I don't believe they work anymore so we
got the gig in like Christmas 2008 and
sort of Neverland tomorrow but I think
part of the the Boy Scout thing is the
first end for a long time only superhero
movie that worked was the Superman one
with Christopher Reeve great and like
that was the movie when when we were
like how the [ __ ] do you make a Captain
America movie they made a Superman movie
and it worked really well like and it
was you didn't feel bad or gross about
him being a boy scout it was totally
appropriate
get back yeah or like Kevin Costner
touchable in Untouchables where like
he's a prick look at and you're like no
but I love him like that's the guy he
should be how pissed off do you guys get
when when there are moments in these
movies that people love to death that
are not your fault and I'm thinking
specifically of the moment when when
when Peggy Carter first encounters
Captain America coming out of the
[ __ ] like listen we get credit for
stuff that people come up with on the
day all the time
we just don't usually tell people
we aliens did we we set the table and it
was our idea to have him shirtless
everyone else wanted him to be really
fine
though we said no he actually should be
in pretty good shape when when they
switch tones between Captain America
first Avengers and origin movie
superhero movie Captain America Winter
Soldier like feels like a spy thriller
felt like our last either by the Condor
tweenage the carnies the condiment and
so much so that am I wrong was Redford
in them yes he was he was so there was
that maybe that parallel was there for
me who decides that was that you did you
guys go like instead of doing can we do
this like if we do a spy movie who came
up with that well we I think we went
around and around as has often happened
we were running around on Winter Soldier
and Civil War trying to figure out what
another movie should be and we wanted
Winter Soldier but they were some people
on it like it's not we just we killed
him two years ago we can't bring him
back right and let him let him be dead
for a while and then I think Kevin
finally he's done this twice stuck his
head in the room and went just like
Winter Soldier I never like oh well [ __ ]
let's do it and then it was the the
genre sort of came from what we wanted
to do with the character and I think a
lot of people might want to do with the
character the one of the most exciting
things about him is he's the man out of
time so what does that mean to be the
man out of time it should not be I don't
like these short skirts right it should
be I like these shoes and that's how we
bring women
it should be I missed Watergate
I missed Vietnam I missed all stuff we
all these compromises we've made as a
society and I why are we doing this
right so that kind of led to the
conspiracy political thriller where I
don't know who I can trust so it's it
really it was what do you want explore
from the character what genre can get
that out of God that's [ __ ] good is
that how the writing of good [ __ ] begins
you ask questions about like like I
would never think of that like you said
they're going like you know but I would
think two people behind a counter that's
it but to sit there and be like I'd
watch that here we are my old friend
think about it from that perspective to
be like well what's interesting about
him he's a man out of time what did he
miss and how does that play into a story
we want to tell like you can the world
is duplicity surround him in a way that
he's not even [ __ ] prepared for right
so it makes for compelling story - well
it's also we're stuck with this guy who
doesn't change you know he's never gonna
be corrupted and become dark cab or or
have worked for Hydra 400 videos but so
if he's gonna stay good you know what do
you put him through
and just like wallowing in the
disgustingness that we live in is it
seems good
ya know and how would he react you know
he's in this time and it's not all great
you know what's he gonna do is he gonna
retire gonna tear the house don't change
the world around him and in that case
Kevin was really instructive because
Kevin came in said I think it's okay to
take down shield cuz we don't we can't
walk in there and say take down shield
that has a ripple effect that you know
that's financial I'd say really so
there's so there's a limit you can't
just be like you know what happens now
spider-man [ __ ] Iron Man
like alright alright we shouldn't do it
but you said so we can I take language
class we could sit and he shooting webs
in his [ __ ] face you like get the
[ __ ] out of marble we now have to
rewrite for yes so wait so there is like
so you guys wouldn't feel comfortable
gone we want to get rid of shield but
Kevin Feige comes in and goes [ __ ]
get rid of shield yeah yeah so he does
that so sometimes he really enjoys
dropping a bomb occasionally and that's
a good one we go oh well now we have a
third act because he can do something
that will matter and that will you know
irrevocably change the universe you know
alright so then we jump to Captain
America three Civil War and you make the
movie that we've all been dying to see
since the opening credits of challenge
of the Superfriends Heroes racing at
other heroes and or villains and [ __ ]
and and we saw it live on screen it was
a beautiful experience a comic book
crossover event movie what what was the
idea what did you go for what was the
model if if Captain America Winter
Soldier was the spy thriller what what
did you guys start talking about they
led you there we had a model for the
Zola plot yeah at the Bucky plot so we
were working on that a long time before
civil war was again that's that's the
other cabin bomber he goes Civil War you
know so he could just walk in he
literally did not come all the way to go
through yeah he went oh my god he's the
marble whisperer
it looks like [ __ ] he pretends he
doesn't love her she loves his [ __ ] and
so the room goes quiet and Joe Russo
just goes oh he just handed us a billion
dollar movie holy crap you know because
he could be if you did it right god yes
and you guys did do it right
[Applause]
well it also helped the time he came
into the room and we were way down the
road drafts I think and he said
yeah you might have to change one thing
because and then he went like that and
we went he would come in and whisper one
word and then he just got to the point
where he's like no words no I just sir I
just make yeah I can guess what that is
that's my kids going to college yes [ __ ]
that's amazing so you hear that you've
got spider-man there's no like [ __ ] we
got a redress it was the best pain in
the ass I've ever had so there was a
moment where you're like two peas like
we got spider-man you like yeah and he
walked away like god damn I mean that's
yes a little bit that's one where we we
had a lot of contingency plans on that
right because you got to get Downey and
you got it you know like is is black
panther are we gonna do that now is that
a good time what do we have for him all
that so we had a lot of early options of
where the pieces could go so what what
if you can tell us what is the non
spider-man version of Civil War look
like he probably recruits a man I think
would be that idea what is it well we
had we had a section where you could
recruit somebody actually went to San
Francisco got it would have been like
San Francisco and yeah Queen that's
right yeah wouldn't nothing as cool I
believe he was watching his daughter
play soccer it wasn't very good
who came up with the idea of the mentor
relationship we did although yeah we did
but the the Downey when you when Tom
gets in a room with Robert Downey jr. it
is the relationship right it's a young
actor with a seasoned actor doesn't want
to [ __ ] up you know like there's so many
there's about three or four lines in
that bedroom scene that are just Downey
you know as I move
I gotta sit here and that's just you
know it was literally telling ya Tom
Holland to move this way and we're all
night Tony Stark he's like this is the
part where you move you're like yeah so
baby am a night robber took that really
well you know the all right so
spider-man gets put into the movie and
that then opens up a larger world in
general right because suddenly you get
to play with toys that you hadn't played
with before yeah lay seeds for the
future yeah not based on Spider Man I
mean look Civil War was a we just had
what 15 14 characters to play with and
try to give everyone a little arc but I
think it we interest anybody what
Panther we entered his Panther Panther
in spider-man with the new ones yeah
yeah we we borrowed Paul Rudd you know
and Everett romps and fan favorite
Everett Ross we did well that's the
beauty of the Marvel Universe is that
you can we need these characters right
we need someone to come in and be the
hard-ass to the Avengers and well that's
William Hurt because we got it right yes
and so you know if we need somebody to
sort of be an attache you know a guy if
you can you know you talk to them if you
do it Black Panther movie you think we
could use him yes okay do it you know
it's it's it's really free it's it's
better than creating a new character
whole cloth because the fans just go
like oh that's fun you get to like pick
out the toys that have been used
previously there's all sorts of like
ripple effects now within within
Hollywood or London because what because
they were making Doctor Strange which
delayed the Sherlock schedule which made
Martin Freeman available to be every
Ross and it was like none of this would
have that wouldn't have been happened if
that hadn't been like you you literally
control the actual universe
did you guys ever since especially in
the beginnings of civil war like when
Kevin leans in and says Panther and then
back out what that character will
eventually mean going forward no I mean
we can't know that Black Panther is
going to you know capture the
movie-going world in the way that it
didn't be so resident and important I
mean we can't even know that they're
gonna make up I don't think no hey Black
Panther movie was on the schedule at
that point it was Kevin went to the
aisle cap anyone here's all the toys oh
my god was at that point yes don't
[ __ ] fight you guys can't break up
too much is riding on this relationship
I invested now voluble let me ask you
this you worked under two different
divisions of Marvel when you guys
started it was Disney correct with
Captain America we started it was
terrible well it was its own thing at
Paramount yeah and then went over to
just that's right marvel's always been
its own production company and paramount
put it out and then Disney puts it out
is there any difference between
paramount and Disney I mean
marketing is really good at Disney oh
well I mean that's a little inside
baseball but like Disney owns it right
so it's in their best interest to give
it a sweet date to you know spend a lot
of money paramount doesn't own it at
that time right but also why is it in
their best interest to give it the
fourth of July date we're gonna give
that to Michael Bay you know that kinda
though but the beauty of Marvel is that
it's it's very insular
like there isn't much difference because
you don't hear from anybody outside of
Marvel you don't get Paramount notes you
don't get Disney notes I mean you get
like Bob Iger watched it and he likes
that joke
there's a joke that Bob the only joke
Bob Iger ever specifically liked it's
not in the movie no we figured out we're
not gonna know make them wait not a very
good joke on the DVD for Bob a super
category what is the in terms of an
infinity war we all knew it would do
very well at the box office but what
does it feel like to write something
that makes that much [ __ ] money it's
nuts
I will say on the morning on Sunday
morning when it's like 10:00 or
something a deadline says it broke the
record I got really emotional because
it's it's not it's not my money but it's
it's a validation of a [ __ ] ton of work
and the idea that that it resonated and
and became slightly historical you know
at least for the moment
it really is really nice I don't think
about you guys clearly your movie fans
you want it wined up an ugly business by
accident and you like movies and and
you've over the course of love and
movies and probably paid attention to
like which ones are the top ones at you
you guys literally have like a [ __ ]
not only a top 20 or a top 10 movie of
all time it's up [ __ ] for three movie
about to be of all time if not [ __ ]
two that's God
that
I would imagine there's you know there's
never a feeling of total security in our
line of work new but there must feel
like when we used to play tag as kids
you'd be like I'm safe I'm on base you
must feel like you're on base right now
like the idea of like I ain't going
anywhere I just vote [ __ ]
$2,000,000,000 Megan movie man oh my god
don't give me that Narnia movie now what
for Italian today of us will never know
that there is some of that but there's
also most of the days spent trying to
crack this movie that we haven't cracked
yeah so like it's like we secretly don't
know how to do this like we're just
sitting there in a room going like is
that good I'm [ __ ] now like is that
good or is that 2 billion dollars worth
of good billion dollar culmination with
18 [ __ ] movies before not all of
which we wrote and it's you know you
can't take all the grinning it took it
win man yes take the win listen to him I
mean given given that you're talking
about the 18 movies that came before
infinity war and and you were left with
a certain amount of pipe yeah of story
that had been told before you was there
ever or were there any elements of
infinity war story that you wish there
had been more pipe for you to work with
okay I know because then I'm gonna have
to ask other I have to I have to Monday
Morning Quarterback other filmmakers and
other films to say would have been nice
if you had done this XY and Z from my
convenience so it's probably not best to
say but like there were times though
because we're writing this while there
they haven't shot Ragnarok yet
Panther ant-man Doctor Strange none of
these movies exist so we're trying to
plot out a movie and then you find out
you go see Ragnarok and go hey they did
everything we were going to do with hope
okay that's true you know and so it's
just like they they late too much
because you know purely as a viewer of a
thing part of part of my my new problems
that I did have with infinity war was
Nigeria superhero movie ever Incredibles
that's good it is good I brought you
here this is the long goddamn con to
have this question answered for me amen
he stands alone
wait ally innate our guest but there's
the moment or part of infinity war
hinges upon the the Peter quill Gamora
relationship yeah and how like part of
his decision-making process towards the
end of it or a lack thereof process is
based upon his love for Gamora
yeah and for me speaking for myself
alone not the very handsome gentleman to
my right the two Guardians movies didn't
quite tee up that depth of love for him
to make as bad a decision as he then
makes that's probably not on gun that's
on us wanting that to be their
relationship it was clearly what that
relationship was heading towards and
it's four years in between movies simi
seemingly guns fault I felt like by the
end of those both of the Guardians
movies I said there was chemistry and
stuff like that and I knew there was
time between I never bumped into that
moment and they kissed even if you were
only dating someone for a few weeks if
you found out her father had murdered
her you would probably hit him in the
face not dark
I would trap them in a shower [ __ ]
I'd scald them to death
[ __ ] I'm worried about the women in
your life I've done more than kissed
some of them the ones for whom I would
punch the end of time and a face for how
do you again you what the ones you would
punch time in the face you have done
more than kiss the ones that I would
have punched the end of time in the face
for well all we can say so much going on
there I got a break
I got a diagram that you would all I can
say is I think they did more than kiss
and I think dranks was watching it's a
very small ship now shut up
alright there was something I've read
about James Gunn wrote the Guardians
dialogue yes or no is that true we he
came in and looked at it all and he
wrote what may be one of the funniest
thing they had visible the invisible
direct stuff that sergeant nuts what do
you have to do that with other
characters to talk to everybody
tyka was particularly helpful because
god thor was gonna be completely
different yeah when we hadn't seen come
here and tell us I don't know if they
could have explained what they were
doing well they they brought footage and
Chris Hemsworth was a hairy Jewish
what we're do where do you go next do
you even step away from marble world
into other things well tomorrow we'll
sit down with Kevin and go through
adventures for you know so like we're
still in it
but you know we started a studio with
the Russo brothers so we're sort of
stepping away and doing this whole new
thing called Agbo because it's the name
that Joe Russo takes when he acts Mack
beau he's crazy act beau it's like
literally just a collection of phonetic
sounds that is like he doesn't want
credit but he likes to take the Cameo so
he's credited as mr. Cozzi Agbo and then
they were like performing a company
where he'd call it act boat for the
moment until we come up with a name and
then you get the official like contract
and still says AG boners like I'm
working for where I took sort of a it
was a weird opportunity where they were
the presidents of story for this studio
so that anything that comes in we read
and help and you know sit with the
writers and rebrand send it back out and
and we'll do a script a year at least
and it was a way to just do more and
have a lot more ownership of it okay
well done in terms of doing more it like
you can't you can't like basically you
do the jobs that they're like you do
this now you can't be like we want to do
this they be like no we need you to do
this this where can you come in and be
like ooh I got an idea for a movie I
want to do both we're talking about
movies that would make money
oh yeah that's a big it's a nice we're
well funded and so that we can sort of
say oh look at that
go get here's well I can't tell that
story but like we [ __ ] process right
because the brothers come to us and they
say do you want to be executives in our
company we go executives anybody's
company what do you think we do yeah and
we're not we don't have the skills and
we've been on this [ __ ] infinity war
movie for four years and
all I want to do is not work that's
right so but we talk about a little bit
and I'm sitting on set one day and I
read an article on my phone and I walk
over to Joe and I go look at this
article he goes huh and by the next day
I get a Texas says we bought it and OH
things can go very quickly this way and
we should we shot it earlier this year I
mean like it's that thing is moot we
didn't write it we didn't know but I
mean like that it's it was fascinating
to know that what good smart people
could do with a little bit of wind at
their backs [ __ ] money man so they got
to you guys got together like we keep
doing this on a regular basis yeah so I
mean after the first ten completely bomb
yeah it may not exactly that's the hope
is that a writer or a director will come
to us and then when they sit in the room
they're getting notes from you know some
guy with an MBA named Josh they're
getting roast notes from guys who know
and so I've slowed them in a different
way it's not you won't get a note like
it's mission we're fine here you're
gonna get let's talk about the midpoint
because it's not doing what you think it
should do that kind of stuff [ __ ]
great so not only do you get to write
but you get to kind of captain a ship as
well like yeah must have sat there over
the course of your career hasn't been
like if I was ever in charge I'd do it
like this now you actually get to do it
like that then but also suddenly find
yourself saying things you like the
writer I have literally said like well
maybe we should just fire the writer and
you know then I had to go sit in the bad
corner because I had become that which I
hate
and then I later he fired the writer and
no we haven't
it sounds very like a Thanos arc right
there yes I got nothing alright so what
we're gonna do ladies and gentlemen is
we're not letting these gentlemen go
because just because we've done a bunch
of questions what me and Mark decided
before the show was generally at this
point in the show we do a Q&A but why
the [ __ ] would you want to ask us [ __ ]
when you could talk to the geniuses that
helped [ __ ] build the Marvel Universe
and wrote the 2 billion dollar grossing
[ __ ] infinity war so what we're gonna
do is switch places with the boys me and
Mark are gonna go out there hold the
microphones to you the boys are gonna
jump up here and hold court and take
your questions
as always the questions come with
rewards man our good friend deacon over
at 40x
has brought us tickets once again for
the 40x theater at LA live if you've
never seen a movie in 4dx what the [ __ ]
are you're wasting your time it's so
amazing if there's snow in the movie it
snows in the [ __ ] theater if somebody
skids out on a motorcycle you smell the
burnt rubber if somebody comes it hits
you in the face they haven't done that
yet but they will goddammit 40x is a
fantastic [ __ ] experience so what
we're gonna do is we've got one two
three four five tickets let's just keep
it to the tickets so just keep it as if
it's five tickets and for you yeah
that's for later we'll need that for
next week five tickets so we got five
questions me and Mark will go out there
and we will ask the questions and we
won't ask ours we'll pick you you'll ask
the questions this is what we ask in
order to be qualified or considered for
the tickets for the two winning tickets
to the 40x theater you have to ask a
really great question you can't just be
like what happens in Avengers for it
they don't [ __ ] know
not yet you just heard them they're like
we're going back to work soon nor could
they tell you even if they didn't
exactly even if they did know you think
they'd share it with you [ __ ] you
so what you want to do is make sure you
ask them they've worked on so many
[ __ ] flicks ask him about right and
ask him about the movies but don't ask
for details about the future that being
said we turn the mics over give it up
for the boys mark
McNelly right
[Applause]
okay man come from back room your hand
went up first come with me we'll let you
ask here we go bringing a guy right up
here hit this wall right in this space
and I'm gonna hold the mic to your mouth
what is it baby my name is Jeff everyone
give it up for Jeff plays each other
[Applause]
happy birthday Jeff ask the boys your
question so this is for all for you and
stop me if I ramble
why do the Netflix movies suck versus
the TV shows that are awesome
auteur stop my variable tours like the
guy that made Gattaca Andrew Nichols
made a non which is basically a black
mirror episode lower-value the guy that
made a right could have been amazing but
it fell very flat yeah these tours that
are given free reign on Netflix with a
lower budget to do what they want to do
seem to bring in lower quality whereas
the TV shows run and fly and are amazing
well I have not been at Netflix spoken
to Netflix my hearing is that the shows
are made on purpose to be put on Netflix
and my other theory is that some of the
Netflix movies are the present-day
equivalent of direct-to-video so that
they wound up on Netflix they didn't go
we have this brilliant idea and we're
going to make it here at Netflix that's
my theory right but neither movies so no
that's true well I buy that what andrew
niccol comes for us we haven't seen
anything so
well done answered without [ __ ] on
the boys give it up for later some
tickets all right I'm going over here
mark barnard gonna pick out the next one
mark go ahead come on over here come to
the wall thank you oh my god don't be
nervous at all man there's just milk men
who've made billions of dollars in front
of it what's your name Susan Susan
everyone give it up for Susan ladies
[Applause]
what's your question Susan my question
is I'm obsessed with Legion what did you
thought about her x-men how they fit
into the Marvel Universe I love to find
her
I think they're not really allowed to
think about it until that deal comes
through and you know cuz Disney's buying
Fox and all that
I assume that Kevin you know better in
bed at night is thinking about what he
could do with them but and his wife is
going but the questions also do like
Legion bleach I've seen the first season
and I thought it was great and smarter
than I am
so I went oh I'm just barely holding on
to this but it's really good and then I
didn't see there hadn't seen a sense I
have a really exhausting five-year-old
who won't let me watch TV so I haven't
seen it but but now blankey on the
actor's name dan cousin Dan Stevens I
met Dan Stevens at a child's dance
recital and he's a lovely man
I'm gonna sweeten the pot on that
question and ask this we all enjoy your
work we love the stories you tell
what do you ingest who do you watch what
are you watching right now you said you
watch the leaves oh yeah but what are
you watching them make some raindrop no
Holly I think he's really good and he
did Legion and you know Fargo and all
that I another thing I don't understand
but I relentlessly watch his West world
I mean I've seen it all but I don't know
if I know everything last episode was
really cool and solved some things and I
don't know so do you have moments where
you're like oh I don't even know where
they're going
like I would imagine the writers like
odd they're gonna do this this this and
this that show less so like I I saw we
were on a panel with Lisa Jo and Jonah
Nolan and I said oh I'm watching
everything I don't know if I understand
everything and she said she was she was
said hold on until a certain episode you
know so she understood that maybe I
didn't everything but at that episode I
would get it she's like they let you
write a vengers it was it's not in my
finest form excellent we got you some
tickets give it up for a late Elvis you
got tickets man at the wall man what's
your name sir TJ TJ give it up for TJ
number one excellent beard game number
two ask the boys a question all right my
question is about infinity war mm and
when you were writing it was it
important for you guys to put the soul
stone somewhere where all of us geeks
and stuff have not guessed yet were you
guys aware of all the theories like was
it important for you guys to put it
somewhere that we have not guessed yet
to make it a surprise
not specifically to torment you were
wrong he's a fringe benefit obviously
but we wanted it somewhere very
meaningful to Thanos not necessarily at
the location being meaningful for him
but and pure to the movie so that it
wasn't we're going over here to revisit
you know we already had that problem
right you knew a lot of places where the
stones were so if we if you knew every
one of them there was gonna be much less
mystery and just on a screenwriting
level it was really important to us to
have a mystery what is Gamora know that
you all don't know so that we it was it
was it's fun just you know there's a
whole thing where every letter spells
out yeah that's my were you aware of all
these theories beforehand and that
affected what you decided
it does not affect what we write it sort
of charms us so if I read it right but
you know it boy you just can't do man
service that way sometimes you read it
and go that's really quite clever and
you know much too clever I mean and I'm
thinking of like everybody's theory that
it was in Wakanda like they can't all be
on earth I know we're a very important
planet but we're not you can't have all
of them here and we have the opportunity
to go to space and then so what was it
the the original he-man movie where they
ran out of money and the rest of it
takes place in a parking lot and then
scene
the money go up there thank you very
much thank you good tickets go get
tickets you want tickets yeah [ __ ] yeah
you get tickets man
excellent question well done beer boy
where you want to go next mark oh so
many pretty this is don't base it on
that look for intelligence oh come on up
here is little light right there what's
your name young camper Elliot everyone
give it up for Elliot Elliot asked the
boys your question my question has to do
with something that I guess started in
Winter Soldier and then continued on
into civil war on earth bringing in Sam
and then his relationship with Bucky how
did that silver war they're fighting
side-by-side they're fighting each other
in Winter Soldier and that moment where
spider-man kicks both our asses and
they're just like it really came up just
being like Steve now has 2 best friends
you know where it's just like literally
just the sort of juvenile impulse on our
part like he has two best and you can
put in this ridiculous rivalry in the
middle of these very serious moments and
the move your seat up there is possibly
my favorite thing in all of the movies
because it's just so petty
it creates a lot of levity reminds you
that it also reminds you those little
things remind you that they're people
you know the Marvel movies are about
people they're not about superheroes
they happen to
have these superhero responsibilities
but they're people who don't have enough
legroom you know and I think that can be
where sometimes some movies fall apart
as they take the superhero before they
take the the person and having little
bits like a rivalry between your best
friends or you know whatever else
reminds you that they're just like you
grab tickets then why can't you get the
last one cat ears get your ass up here
man everyone give it up the cat ears you
have you had something you wanted to ask
us on Twitter right or do you have
something different save it for us so
now do this with them all right here you
go you got the boys asking what you
wanted them hey um I just first want to
say Danis was one of the first villains
that seemed just as real in the comic
book in the movie as he did in the comic
book maybe juggernaut and Deadpool too
but do you think that there is any
possible way of making not even just
Fantastic Four but a Doctor Doom that is
right yes of course yeah and now would
you get how would you do it one I would
do the thing that they never do which is
to stick to the comic book and make him
the king of his own country
like Darth Vader it works in Star Wars
just do it again I was like he's an
American scientist who's jealous over
their relationship you know you don't
know why they would they did that no I
know I mean I I can completely
understand the impulse you know it's
like you have to make it relatable you
have to relate it to these characters
you want them all to have a pass
together you know I get it but it
doesn't work because he has to wind up
in a ridiculous place you know unless
you're just gonna put him in a leather
jacket and call him like Vic yellow you
gotta go put on a cape you know either
either you're gonna leave yourself the
task of having to get all the way over
to a guy in a cape or just make him a
guy in a cape thank you sure go get your
tickets man you win that's the last of
tickets we get to ask questions as well
I'll let you think of one while I
present one you go first one ready and
this might be a bit unfair and [ __ ] but
this isn't me asking you to [ __ ] on
anybody this is just me asking experts
what they would do in this situation
how you [ __ ] on this person you guys
have made wonderful films about people
and we think I think I just heard the
recipe right there you don't make movies
Buster burrows you make movies about
people and they half and half these
powers that being said if somebody
offered you a [ __ ] ton of money and
sways you to the dark side and said fix
these [ __ ] movies how would you fix
the DC Universe
[Applause]
[Music]
be very careful you might work for them
one day
I know weather should be I mean I would
look at what Marvel did out of necessity
in that they didn't have their a-list
characters they didn't have spider-man
they didn't have the x-men and they went
down the line I'm finding I mean pretty
[ __ ] famous desired man but he's you
know he wasn't there
and they made a really good movie on I
might put Batman and Superman and
everybody else I mean Wonder was doing
fine aside for a second go through the
vast world and go that guy or that girl
and go let's just make a really good
movie and not a universe you know there
there's a lot of spaghetti being thrown
at the wall I mean my familiarity with
the DC Universe is not that great so I
mean I can just go sort of strategically
it's make one right to quote Justice
League save one person oh my god you'd
fix them with their own advice
perception on yourself dr. Lecter
alright that's my question you jump in
nice place I jump in
hi guys man first-time listener what can
I get you I want to know if there is a
character in the Marvel Universe that
you have tried to put in a movie that
you have not been able to when you're
dying oh what a great [ __ ] question
that is I mean I will say this every
time you make a movie with Nate more he
tries to put Joey Chapman Joey Chapman
is he captain Britain or Union Jack yeah
he tries to put Union Jack in the movie
he will succeed I warn you
there are characters who I love who I'm
sure someone else will get ahold of and
do great things with I never we've never
tried to put them in like we get to put
them in like we got to put Zola into
movie yes
you know like it's I have well yeah I've
wanted to put MODOK in yeah and it's
very hard to go here's the supporting
character the giant head and then we're
gonna get on with the story
we're just came doing for me information
that's like I got a design the whole
movie around the guy with a giant hand
what you're describing is the scene from
Total Recall where Arnold Schwarzenegger
and talks to [ __ ] quato yes just to
get information from the head in the
belly it did work say there's a
blueprint I have love for MODOK and I
and I also think properly done you'd be
[ __ ] terrifying like you go get like
you look all the way down the hall and
like this huge head comes around the
corner and then that's coming and it's
awesome somebody should make a really
good Moon Knight movie
[Applause]
complicated in what way is a complicated
because he's Batman II it's because he
got really good later at the beginning
it was kind of good but also kind of
cheesy and then later on he got kind of
awesome but the awesome part kind of
needs the cheesy part to make sense so
it gets very convoluted very quickly
fair enough but he's Jewish which is
nice you got our yeah we'll finish up
with before you leave this world what
are you guys separately or together
what's something you want the the
screenplay
you want to write obviously not the one
that's the personal one or is something
we've never heard of but if there's toys
you can play with what would you like to
do go huh I mean I'm gonna answer the
question the way you don't want to
answer the question like we're gonna try
to do a couple more so we started on
biopics and true story so we have a few
of those under our belts and so we're
currently I would yeah we're currently
doing sort of a true-life important
resonant you know rip from the headlines
thing that charms me and and I feel like
I'm doing good by if we can never get it
made you know so that that's another
part of my career I'd like to it you
know it's hard it's weird because it's
again it like we can't get bigger so we
got to get different and it's we've had
a we've had the rare pleasure of having
to move our goal posts right because I
could not predict that we'd had these
kind of movies under our belts and had
this type of attention so like now what
you know what's Willy Wonka says at the
end you know what did the guy who got
everything he ever wanted you know
happily ever after well I'm 48 I got
more time I'm not literally I'm really
after effort I got to do something
alright so it's got to be lateral or
smaller or different you know smart do
well there's its meaning that we we we
finally got the option on a series of
books
that we want to make into a TV show we
don't have time and it's it's a series
called the Branstetter books that are in
and out of print from the early 70s of
the 90s it's a he's a gay private
detective and it they're really good and
you could make a really good like like a
Long Goodbye hen episode [ __ ] up
Southern California you know because
every writer wants to do their detective
story and this one has enough of its own
elements that you go like I finally
understand you know it's a detective I
could by existing in the real world and
I'd long to have the time to do it but
before the option I when is the day that
you guys will go back to work on
Avengers 4 is it soon tomorrow it is
tomorrow 7 o'clock status of Avengers 4
is that we shot it we shot it but it's
not due for a while and there's please
certainly but you know there's time for
reshoots and fixing and we're just you
know scrubbing through it now and and
the Russo brothers have been in there
for a few weeks now after the press tour
and all that and I think you know the
whole team's getting together tomorrow
how can a man goddamn special well it's
disheartening to come off of the one
that's all done and made 2 billion
dollars and get in the room that just
full of parts this is a lot of ash
[Applause]
oh my god we had a tremendously special
night
thanks for being here or hopefully you
all enjoyed it mark where are you get on
the other 7 chemistry into but
unfortunately like all the good things
they must come to an end
tonight's show is officially out of nine
ladies gentleman have you had a good
time this we cannot thank you enough for
showing up
we thank the boys for showing up we
thank a scum and villainy canteen our
home here in Hollywood JC the bar but
the show is nothing but dick jokes and
navel-gazing without the man to my left
to give it up for the guy who does the
thinking on this job mr. Marvin Arden
and that is Batman on Batman for this
week I'm Kevin Scott mark barnard tune
in next time same bat time same bat
Channel SModcast calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith
[Applause]
[Music]
you